this is a production of cornell
university
great thank you so much for uh such a
kind introduction and giving me an
opportunity to speak
in front of such a wise and esteemed
audience of
plant science planned scientists of
cornell university
so um at my research i was lucky enough
to develop
my research from my phd all the way
through
my position as a as a group leader so
i'm going to take you
through that journey starting with
um what really amazed me as a plant
scientist
is that plants although they have their
preferred habitats they still manage to
to grow over over a wide range of
different habitats from
almost desert-like habitats where the
there is a high range of
daily temperatures all the way to the
tropics where the range of temperatures
is very narrow humidity is very high
and what's also quite interesting is
that we as a human species
manage to build agricultural systems
throughout those different habitats as
well so we've got people that are doing
agriculture
in australia as crazy as it might sound
uh to europe and india and africa
so but right now as probably most of you
are aware of
our agricultural systems are being
challenged by the climate
climate change and in here we've got an
overview of what are the challenges to
the agriculture in general
and you see that a lot of those risks
are represented by blue
which is representing the water
availability or rather the lack of water
availability
so many times when there is no fresh
water available people are doing
irrigation
which in turns is is resulting in in
soil salinization over the long term
and so how can we how can we improve or
manage that
our agricultural systems are resilient
against those changes
so one way of doing this is to
domesticate species that are already
loving the extremes for example this
desert rose which
in my photoshop fantasy i put some very
juicy fruits
normally the fruits of the desert rose
are very not very appealing to it
but maybe with some with some genetic
engineering we can domesticate
them and make them produce something
that we as a humans are interested in
another strategy is looking into an
intra-specific variation so the
variation that already exists within the
species we like to eat or use for other
purposes
or exploring the variation within the
species that are closely related
to the species that that we like to eat
so but before we start to equip our
agricultural systems with all of those
different mechanisms of resilience
we still need to understand what are
actually the plant responses to applying
those resilience mechanisms as
efficiently as possible
with as little yield damages as
as possible as well so i'm focusing on
the salt stress
and salt is usually occurring in the
soil so the plants
when they are exposed to the salt the
first reaction is to try to pump all of
the ions
out of the root against the gradient and
as pumping anything against the gradient
it is very energetically expensive
and over the long term not very
efficient
so um another part of the response is
whenever the salt
is accumulated in the soil in very
patches
and the plant will propagate its roots
mainly in the portions of the soil that
is not that much affected by salinity
and it's known as a negative halotropism
which we described
in the crystal slab with carlos galvan
and puria
however at some point plant needs to
take up the water so
it takes up ions and uses them as an
osmoticum to to be able to
increase the hydraulic conductivity into
the root and all the way so that the
plant can continue transpiring
if the salt concentration is high at
some point the leaves that are the
oldest
that have been exposed to salinity for
the longest time they are going
undergoing a premature senescence and
the yield is probably slightly decreased
but if the concentrations of the salt in
the soil
is reaching the photosynthetic apparatus
in the younger leaves
they are also undergoing premature
senescence and the yolk is
basically negligible of those plants
so as you see the whole
the the this overall salinity tolerance
of the plant is pretty
complex thing it's comprised of multiple
processes
that are compounding on top of each
other so that's why
there is this example of the study of
qatari dao from a decade ago right now
where they studied
the different accessions of arabidopsis
and looked throughout time
when watered with quite high salinity so
this is equivalent of
red sea salinity and they looked at how
those plants are surviving or not
surviving
throughout time and they failed to
identify any genetic components
because they were looking at selling
tolerance
as a whole well
when you're trying to look at map all of
those different processes at the same
time you simply don't have enough
statistical power to do so
so what i was told very early on in my
career is to focus
focus on specific specific tissues or
specific processes that you hypothesize
are contributing to cellulite tolerance
and and i might comment on that later
when when talking about high throughput
phenotyping facility
but without knowing any better i decided
to focus on root system architecture
so um when you when as a phd student i
started growing those arabidopsis plants
on increasing concentrations of soil if
salt
i observe that yeah plants the more salt
you add the smaller they grow
not very surprising but the question
that i really really was excited about
addressing
is is it on is the salt or stress in
general
only delaying plant development or is it
really reprogramming it
so i scratch my hair my my head for a
couple of minutes to
to figure out how are we going to do
that
um and i decided to to to look at the
dynamics of
root development throughout time and
under different soul stress conditions
so um what we basically did is we
germinated the plants
under um control conditions for four
days and at four they all
the the root there's just the main roots
there's not much architecture per se
to a plant so at four day we
transplanted those seedlings
into zero 75 and 125 millimolar of salt
stress
and we scan those plates
very high-tech technology scanning off
the plates every second
day and to observe how the plants are
developing
under those different conditions and
then later on we also quantified
um this development using a semi
automatic or semi-manual
uh software called easy rhizo
so once we had the heaps of data and i
had to think about how to synthesize it
in a way that i can really make
comparisons so what i did is i set up a
very simple model to describe
the growth of the root system
architecture per se so i divided it into
three components so we're starting with
this
main root that is just a tiny little
root at the four days
and that root is growing with a certain
speed and i could fit a quadratic
function into that
sorry so you've got the starting
starting point
and then you've got the growth rate of
the of the root
at some point you also have lateral
roots popping up and the speed at which
the lateral roots are emerging
is also the increase of the lateral root
number so we can also fit
similar type of function in there and
then you also have the outgrowth of
those lateral roots which you can then
measure with
like fit an average latitude length
speed to it
so basically you can summarize the
entire dynamic
of the root system architecture in just
three numbers
and by adding and multiplying them
together we could
definitely predict the total root size
of the entire root system which was
really really cool
so when i quantified those all of those
different parameters
in the three different conditions for
the main roots
number of lateral roots and average
lateral root growth
and what i observe is that you've got
the decrease the more salt you add the
slower individual components are growing
again not very surprising but because
we're using the same
kind of family of mathematical formulas
so this is a quadratic formula
and we can actually compare the
differences caused by salt between
individual components so when we
calculate the relative
change in the main root number of
lateral roots and every flat root
growth between those components we
observed that in colombia which is a
reference genotype of arabidopsis
the main root is impacted much more
severely than the number of lateral
roots and average lateral root lengths
in both conditions
which was pretty pretty exciting because
it means that
they are not only growing just slower
they are really growing
differently because if they would be
impacted with exactly the same
um extent then we wouldn't see any of
the differences in the relative
change right okay so then
we quantified multiple accessions so we
classified them uh some of them that
were responsible
responding exactly the same as colombia
some of them were having exactly the
opposite so the main root kept on
growing but the lateral roots
not so much so um we also
performed um quantification of the root
system architecture on a wider
population which comprised
accessions and for this this population
back then when i was starting a phd we
had a data set of 250 000 snips
available
which allowed us to do a genomic
association study
and so connecting our different
phenotypes of the root system
architecture with the snip markers so
here you see a typical output of the
genome association and manhattan plot
association strength on the y-axis and
five chromosomes of arabidopsis
and here is an association that we were
most excited and the association was
with average latitude length
um and why were why were we the most
excited about this association is
basically because it was
association with hkt1 which stands for
high affinity potassium transporter
so that's the beauty of salt stress
field so in multiple plant species there
are number of hkt1 in arabidopsis
there's only one hkt1
and it's not transporting potassium but
it's made from transporting sodium
into the cell and we were very excited
because hkt1 was already previously
mapped by
avon baxter and to be associated with
sodium accumulation trade that we know
was very much correlated with selling
its tolerance but it was not previously
associated with root development
so we made use of the lines that were
available
for those hkt1 which um
where over expression lines in the xylem
popery cycle which is a native
expression site for hkt1 so why is hkt1
correct
correlated with salinity tolerance when
it's actually pumping ions in
um so it's the key is where is the
native expression of the hkt1 so it's
expressed in the xylem propery cycles
which are the cells that are surrounding
the transpiration stream
and are basically sucking all of the
ions out of the transpiration stream
so that that that sodium is not
accumulating to the toxic levels
into the into the chute so when we
looked at those lines and
the ingo miller generated those lines in
both columbia and c24
background so here we've got the
background lines and the two
lines that have an over expression of
hkt1
when we grew them under control
conditions there is not much difference
but as soon as we added salt
we observed that there is a the the
plants are really suffering and they're
mainly
suffering in their lateral development
as you can see
demonstrated in here well no significant
differences were
observed under control conditions so
that was exciting but then we had to
think like how is that possible so
hkt1 as i already told you is expressed
around xylem for parasites
around excellent vessels and that's
exactly the same tissue that is giving
origin to the lateral roots
so if you over accumulate those ions
in this very tiny precious little
lateral root primordia
they're going to die so we thought okay
this is a good hypothesis let's test it
in another
biological system so there are lines
wheat lines so
wheat has five hkt1
genes and uh to be to make it easier
hkt1 that is the most homologous to
arabidopsis one is nax2 locus
and in here we've got the introgression
lines of
another hkt1 and an hkt1 that is
homologous to arabidopsis so this is the
nax2
and we got those those lines from
ranamans and richard james from csiro in
australia
and we screened them very early on in
their development for changes
in the interseminal root length lateral
lateral root number and lateral root
length under control conditions and salt
stress
so for the seminal root length we didn't
really observe that much of a difference
either in control or insult stress but
when it came to number of
lateral roots or average lateral root
lengths
we saw a little bit of a phenotype under
control conditions but it was definitely
much more pronounced under soul stress
that those lines with high hkt1
expression in the weed
developed more lateral roots which is
exactly the right phenotype in exactly
the wrong direction
so we were again scratching back to the
drawing board scratching our heads
how is that possible and reviewing some
basic developmental biology and
differences between the monocots and
dicots
well hkt1 in wheat is still expressed
around
the asylum and the lateral roots are
actually originating from the
phloemperic cycle
so hkt1 is giving much better um
protection for the in the in the wheat
without damaging the lateral
development unlike in the in the
arabidopsis so this is at the moment
the working hypothesis that we're
dealing with
another interesting phenomenon that we
observe is
that when we supplement it so hkt1 is
mainly transporting
sodium but it also transports a little
bit potassium and salt stress is not
only about iron accumulation but also
getting a disbalance between sodium and
potassium
so we were wondering if we add a little
bit of potassium to the media together
with our
souls can we then alleviate this
this um dramatic decrease in lateral
root development
and the answer is yes we can although in
the background lines the number the
average lateral root length went down
because
you've got higher overall osmolarity
and we we could we could observe a very
small but still significant the increase
in the lateral development in the in the
lines over expressing hkt1
so we thought okay let's use hkt1 as a
tool to learn
more about what's happening to the
lateral development
undersold stress and so we did what many
people do
when they want to move forward and and
do a hypothesis generating experiment we
did aaron asec
where we again gener germinated those
seedlings on the control conditions we
transferred them to four different
treatments we let the seedling be there
for 24 hours and then we harvested only
the root
from all four genome types per
experiment so
one sample consisted of 150 to 200
seedlings so you can imagine i was
harvesting forests of arabidopsis
we had three replicates per line per
condition and we only harvested roots so
after doing oops
sorry not the right direction so after
doing differential expression
for individual line between control and
individual treatments we
also did a double differential
expression
between the background line and the line
over expressing hkt1 so we've got a
response not only to stress
but also to hkt1 which is background
specific
so after we did that so here we see
differential expression in response to
salt and hkt1 and c24 background
and here we've got the same for the
columbia background and here we've got
salt and potassium for c24 salt and
potassium for colombia
and when we looked at the overlapping
genes surprisingly enough
we didn't find that many genes that were
overlapping between two different
backgrounds
but we also know that those two
different lines are having very
fundamentally different responses
to stress so we were in the end we were
happy to have
any overlap i would say and when you
have little overlap it's easier to pick
the genes that you're going to focus on
so one of the genes that we focused on
was
shared between colombia and c24 response
to
salt nhkh1 and it was encoding tmac2
which is a negative aba regulator
and when we looked at the relative
expression of this tmac2
in the columbia an over expression line
in c24 and it's over expression line we
observed that the pattern was actually
yeah it was significantly changed but it
was exactly the opposite
which was very very interesting so uh we
couldn't get our hands on
any of the mutants of the tmac but we
did measure
aba accumulation in collaboration with
sorry in collaboration with jang yuvang
from salim albabili lab in kaust and
what we did what we observed is the
pattern that was exactly complementary
to an expression of negative aba
regulators so whenever our
negative aba regulator was upregulated
the aba levels were down
whenever it was downregulated the aba
levels were
up so there might be some some feedback
mechanisms between this
aba negative regulator and the aba
biosynthesis itself
which i think is quite interesting so at
the moment we're generating the crispr
mutants
in in all of those background of
c24 colombia and both tissue-specific
over-expression lines to see
do we have uh can we reverse this
decrease in latitude
emergence and result stress another gene
that we also explored was
tip 2-2 which encodes a tonoplast
interesting protein
um which is supposedly an aquaporin
although
nowadays there there is an increasing
evidence that aquaporins are
transporting much more than just water
so over here we observe that in both
lines
of over expression the upright the tip
2-2 expression was upregulated
and luckily we could get our hands on
tip 2-2 mutant
in colombia background and we explored
their root system architecture under
control
salt and more salt conditions for total
root length number of lateral roots and
main root lengths
and we didn't see that much of a
difference under control conditions but
as soon as we added salt
the difference in the total root length
was becoming more and more pronounced
and we figured out that it's mainly
because the tip-2-2 mutants developed
much more number of latitudes
so again right now we're generating the
crispr mutants in the background of the
uas hkt1
lines and their retrospective background
lines
and also we're working in collaboration
with steve tireman
and and caitlin bird in australia with
um the transport properties of this tip
2-2 because it hasn't been that well
characterized yet
so this was all focusing on the root
system architecture and as a root
biologist i tend to be very proud
because
i'm working on the on the hidden part of
the of the part
of the hidden half of the plant but it's
still a half
so talking to mark we realized that we
don't really know what's happening to
the root to shoot ratio
in salt stress unlike we know what's
happening in the drought
so together with first rashid we
developed this
tool that was able to transfer our
scanned pictures
into just green white and blue pixels
and it's a semi-manual
analysis tool so i only say it's
semi-manual because if you as a phd
student in postdoc
get to work with semi-automatic making
all of those manual corrections you
realize that it's quite still
a lot of manual work um but
we still did it it wasn't perfect
because we were still not able to deal
with plans that where the roots are
overlapping
so there might be still a little bit of
an error but we were willing to take
that risk
of that error and use the tool to
calculate the growth rate
of the root and the shoot and here again
we fitted
very simple mathematical functions and
here we're using exponential functions
to estimate the root growth and the
shoot growth
of the all 350 accessions of arabidopsis
again
and again the more stress you add the
slower the plants are growing
but the more interestingly is that when
you look at the route to shoot
growth rate ratio oops right
and you see that it's not really
responding in a certain way so the
plants are not getting
rootier as they would under drought
stress but actually they are just
getting dysregulated so the roots and
the shoot growth rate is not as well
coordinated as it is under control
conditions
but it's just going both ways
so we did genomic dissociation
and we used shoot per total seedling
area as
our indicator of root to shoot ratio
among other things
and one of the associations we found was
on chromosome 3
and this association was in the duf 247
which if you don't know stands for
domain of unknown function
247 so so far for creative
naming anyway so it was in the in the
valley
of other duf 247 and
we looked at the sequence diversity
across
hapmap accessions we observed that there
are some insertions and deletions and
that there is some sequence
divergence in here and when we use the
newer
snip set containing 10 million snips
that was provided to us by arthur corta
well the threshold went up but we found
much more
snips that were still above our previous
threshold of six
so we found around 50 associations 50
snips
within this duf-247 so
what we also did is we looked at all of
the snips that were in the coding region
of the duf-247 and performed haplotype
analysis so we grouped
now the accession is not per snip but
just per the clusters of snips
and we found that cluster 11 um
was significantly shootier than the
cluster one which contained our favorite
columbia
zero so when we started to clone
those different alleles together with
michelle sorry
michelle alcatani who was a phd student
in
mark's lab and we observed that there
are actually
two huge 200 base purse insertions
in here and they are leading to a
premature stop codon which is basically
resulting in lack of the duf domain
so um we also know
that there are 26 other duf 247 in
arabic genomes
the closest similarity are the dufs 247
that are within
within the same genomic region but they
are showing very little expression
similarity so right now in the lab at
the bti
haley sussman is working on the
functional characterization of the
different tdna insertion mutants of
not only the daf that we're interested
in but also all of the other ones that
are in the neighboring um regions and
also
figuring out where is this duf 247
localizing to
liang is looking at the evolutionary
context of the duf 247
in collaboration of course with andrew
nelson
and anna nelson is
doing molecular characterization of the
duf-247 looking at calcium binding
dimerization
and also at those characteristics of the
domains
so now for the whatever time i've got
remaining i want to kind of switch gears
and talk about
like do we really need to focus on
individual traits so traditionally
as a biologist we learn to use forward
or reverse genetics
and to identify the cor the relationship
between a gene and a phenotype
or a phenotype and an allelic variation
within the gene
in in terms of forward genetics
and those there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that and we learned a lot we
learned
which processes are are important for
celine tolerance
which genes are among other genes
contributing to that
and how are all of those different genes
uh interacting
but what we're what we're still missing
from one picture
is all of the other traits that could
potentially contribute that we are not
even hypothesizing or contributing
so this is i think where high throughput
phenotyping is coming in
and high throughput enabled discovery
because
where then you can think about you can
think about
your in in the interesting process that
that is of your interest
and without the need to focus on only
one phenotype that you can score
um so you can score multiple fiends
so those are basically a relation to a
fee into a phenotype is the same as
gene to a genotype so it's very
elemental
function of the phenotype uh you can
score them throughout time
and and the the denser you go you can
also observe very transient processes
which are still occurring but we're very
often missing when we're doing it in the
field or when we're doing
doing phenotyping um that is destructive
so we can not only quantify how the
fiend contributes to overall plant
performance
but also what is the individual
contribution of the fiend to each other
and how they are reacting and how those
interactions are changing throughout
time
and throughout um different conditions
so um i've got some uh papers that are
already that
where we're looking into how can we use
high throughput phenotyping
into gaining more insight gaining more
insight about the process in general
looking beyond one phenotype and beyond
one gene
so one example is this paper that was
published with gigi gao
in plant phenomics where we basically
took colombia
and a mutant that we know is heat
sensitive and we
phenotyped it in the with the high
throughput facility
and we developed a logistic regression
model
where we trained it on the subset of our
data
and um and then the the model was able
to distinguish whether a plant was a
mutant or a wild type based only on the
inputted phenotypes
and then we could retest it on the
remaining set of the data
and and usually machine learning is
being seen as this black box
but i'm really interested to look what's
inside and making that black box
transparent to see
which of the traits are actually used by
this logistic regression
with more seriousness are being taken
more seriously into consideration
how to make a decision and like this we
can also learn which of the traits are
contributing
to this distinction between mutant or
wild type
or stress and non-stress plans and
things like that and i think that
one of the this might be a powerful
approach later on
another paper that is currently under
revision but you can find the bio
archive
version of it is um a paper that we
worked together with maryam aulia
who focused on early responses to salt
stress so she developed a protocol to
apply salt stress in the soil
and then phenotype the plants for the
subsequent seven days
so we end up with this big data tsunami
which we then used for multivariate
analysis and machine learning and in
this case we didn't use logistic
regressions but we used
tree based models and
and that's allowed us to identify the
traits that have a high contribution to
overall plant size
under control and soil stress conditions
and also
took that information when we were
reviewing the genomic association output
so we knew
which of the traits we should give a
little bit more love to and attention
and so that led us to identification of
this uncharacterized protein kinase
which affects um quantum yield under
light adapted conditions
and and then also the mutants show the
significant
differences um with their um
with the uh with colombia for the for
just
overall plant area and plant growth
which i think is pretty excited and i
don't think we would have focused on
one of the 700 associations that we
found
without doing this step all right um
i don't really have that much time to
talk about that but i also was involved
in developing multiple tools for
dealing with high amount of data so mv
app
is one of the results where it allows
you to do
quick pre-processing of your data
identify outliers which
usually takes quite a lot of time and
but also evaluate the traits for the
broad sense heritability
do some curve fittings so you can
estimate the growth rate summary
statistics
but also hypothesis testing so we
usually do anova but nobody
really does assumptions testing
assumptions for anova so
it's there you don't have any excuse now
and but also a lot of hypothesis
generating
uh tools which is quantum regression
clustering correlation analysis pca
so all of this is based on r but we just
package it into
a user-friendly clickable approach and
there's also a youtube channel and a
twitter account where you can find quite
a lot of resources on how to use that
we're dedicated in mind maintaining this
tool
and and and keeping it updated based on
extremely positive feedback from the
community
so just quickly what i want to do in at
the bti during my
appointment as an assistant professor in
here i want to focus on
species that are naturally tolerant to
stress
and one of them is solan and
pimpinellifolio which is the closest
relative
of tomato it's native to the west coast
of south america
and and it's it's super tolerant because
it survived in my garden in saudi arabia
so i think that's that's a very good
argument for working on something i'm a
very poor gardener
and so faye from the bti they released
the recently
released the reference genome for the
pimping elifoleum
and we at cause sequence 230 accessions
uh which were right now processing for
the snip calling and making it as a
as a useful genomic association resource
so what we want to do with this
population is going to be our guinea pig
together with andrew nelson which i was
hired
together with andrew as a cluster hire
you can read all about it on the bti
website i'm not going to talk that much
but what we want to do is we want to
phenotype this
population using traditional high
throughput phenotyping so scoring growth
chlorophyll fluorescence uh doing
multi-spectral imaging things like that
but also
using raspberry pi phenotyping which
will allow us to have much higher time
density
so look at the look at the changes that
are occurring within minutes
of the plant and that will allow us to
identify things that are very much
very often overlooked like quiescent
phase that plants undergoing after
strength stress exposure
and also how quickly the plants recover
and what is what are the dynamics of
this recovery
so those high um
high quality changes in plant growth
will allow us to
select time points at which we're going
to collect more molecular phenotypes
such as transcriptomics metabolomics
epigenomics
and using all of this data we're going
to be able to perform basically like
gwas on steroids
which is not only association between
your phenotype and the snip but also
your phenotype and the transcript levels
or metabolome levels
and then this layered approach is going
to allow us to
see which of the associations are very
stable
and and confirmed by different layers
and also pick ones
pick the ones that that that we're the
most excited about
in the larger scheme of things uh we're
we have a very evil plan
on exploring not only company volume but
closely related cultivated tomato and
then also
branch out to all the brassy cases and
later on also to monocots
and this comparative framework will
allow us to
establish which of the resilience
mechanisms are very short-range
applied and only found in within the
species
medium range so applied and found within
the closely related species
and long range and that's that kind of
framework will allow us to see
what are the mechanisms that are easily
transferable between the species
and what are the mechanisms that are
more species specific
um yeah and in the end
i wanted to thank you for your attention
and but also my group that i did a phd
so this is krista tester in clubs back
at
university of amsterdam christa right
now moved on to wageningen university
she was an excellent mentor and gave me
quite a lot of freedom in my phd
then i did a pg postdoc in mark tester's
lab so here
is a basically a look a view from the
lab we're having
view we're at the red sea coast so mark
was also an excellent
mentor and and all of those amazing
people
were were great colleagues and and oops
sorry
um and also all of the collaborators and
colleagues
students from kaust and of course
last but not least i wanted to thank all
of my new colleagues here at the bti
who are a wonderful team and to work
with so hayley
and liang and of course andrew and anna
who
were absolutely instrumental when i was
starting here
just clueless about where everything was
who was doing what and also the bti
senior leadership team who managed to
get me from saudi arabia
to ithaca from all the places during
this
weird time of kovit and
that's it i would like to welcome all
the questions
after a presentation it's always like is
anyone else there
still you can unmute yourselves and ask
a question or you can just put it in
chat
so magdalena this is voitek um
so in your g was on steroids
like i you mentioned and i saw it in the
slide that you want to
take the environment into account as
well and i wonder like
uh if you could elaborate on that like
i'm curious like how and are you going
to do it in practice
yeah so do you so the environment the
environmental geos
it's it's not our idea i think it
originated from ed buckler
um from over the road um so what he
uh what he's do what we're what we would
be doing then in
environmental g was is collecting the
gps
coordinates of all of the accessions
where they are originating in
and then you use the environmental
traits so
annual precipitation uh temperature
stuff like that as your phenotypic
traits
so that that would then if you've got an
overlapping association between your
phenotype and this environmental geos
it would say oh this is something that
is causing
local adaptation to this specific
climate to this specific
environmental variable does that answer
your question by deck
yeah sure and so that then you have to
like pay attention to a geographical
distribution of the
whatever lines or accessions you're
collecting right
uh you would no well so you would always
have
a kinship matrix as your co cofactor in
your duos that that would that would not
exclude
the need for that uh because running
that as a co-factor or running it as a
separate
genome association is very very
different
but what would yeah so we would be able
to do that but
i also realized based on the work that
i've done on arabidopsis and a lot of
people are like oh you know all of those
successions are running
are from the coast and therefore they
must be more affected by salt
well so this a stress that is very
difficult to make this kind of
assumptions based on just global data
because
um yeah it's it's very depending on the
type of the soil that you've got and
things like that
i would assume that the the west coast
of south america
would be less disturbed by by that but
i don't know i think it would be still
good to good to do it especially
with the stresses that we're planning to
work on so not only salt but also heat
stress
and drought stress so those parameters
are much
much easier to estimate from the
environment and the data that is
available
thanks
other questions anyone okay i see
nothing in chat
okay let's thank mike laner for our
fantastic seminar
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu